i heard you talking about this in
another interview
another relic of of our era being gen
x is that we grew up in a time in which
we just weren't exposed to the truth of
possibilities like i remember going to i
went to a really nice college and
i was unclear on what i wanted to do and
i went to the
campus you know career counseling center
and it was just
brochures on consulting companies and
applications for
investment banks and i was like is this
it like is this all that
is available to me there was no as you
had mentioned in this other interview
there was no
youtube you couldn't pull up videos of
the people that you
revered and respected and have them tell
you
exactly how they did it so there was
this sense of
these people are inaccessible what
they're doing is not possible for the
average human being
they were baked as geniuses from the
get-go and i'm just gonna have to go
you know pursue this sort of mundanity
um yeah they left they leave out the
story of the geniuses right
and so wait you went to stanford i did
yeah yeah
but now don't you think stanford is the
kind of the opposite right like
i mean i was there at a transition
period
you know it was this great institution
but
um it was right on the precipice of it
becoming like
the tech place to be you know palo alto
at the time was still
a pretty bucolic little college town
and of course there was intel and ibm
and things like that
and a lot of my you know
friends were studying computer science
and the like but there wasn't that sense
of like
silicon valley and this is where it's
all happening that came later
and i have lots of friends that went off
to make billions of dollars and do that
and
you know i just wanted to read books and
do other things like
you know i sort of wasn't plugging into
that
sensibility at the time but yeah i'm
sure it's different now i mean now it's
like a giant metropolis it's completely
different
did you know how much work
you were going to have to do that was
that i i guess
to get into stanford you have to do it
to do anything
to do like that was a thing that came as
and
to this day comes as a surprise to me is
the amount
of i don't care how smart you are the
amount of
just the crazy amount of work like
um you know i don't know i just
that came as a surprise to me i didn't
know it was going to be
to do something of consequence or to do
like oh follow your path or whatever was
going to be
i i can't believe how much work it is
and how long it takes
right it takes so long even though
you're doing all this work like
every waking hour yeah well i look at it
like that i mean i was never
super talented in anything that i've
that i was doing or
that i continue to do i'm a grinder so
i'm never afraid of the hard work like i
relish that and i see that as my
advantage long term like as i'll outwork
anybody and
bridge that talent deficit gap to the
best of my abilities and that's the way
i looked at
you know get that's how i got into
stanford and that's how i tried to keep
pace with these students that were much
smarter than me
and you know talented in ways that i
couldn't possibly imagine
but yet you know i think i think
on top of that is is this patience and
appreciation for the length of time that
it takes to do
anything well right and i look at your
path you know i want to talk about the
sobriety aspect of it but
it's you know it's been a 10-year period
of you kind of figuring out who you are
and what you want to be
until you get to this point where you
can synthesize all of these experiences
that you've had and deliver them in a
way that
you know i think you're you're hitting a
certain stride right now in terms of
what you're doing and how you're
communicating with the world that's a
reflection
of that 10-year period of work that
you've put in and
you know the things that i i'm 54 like i
didn't start figuring out who i was or
what i wanted to do until i was like
41 42 years old and i've spent the last
nine years
doing this thing and i only feel now
like i'm starting to understand
what it is exactly it takes time and i
think everybody
particularly now in the way that the
culture is
with this you know kind of hack your way
to success and
you know this priority on trying to find
the shortcut we're missing the bigger
picture
it's in that struggle it's in that
journey that you develop
the resonance that will make you great
in whatever field it is that you're
trying to
pursue so you went and you did
you went to law school right yeah i mean
that was a
giant mishap yeah so i went i
uh i grew up in washington dc
i was a swimmer went to stanford swam
there
graduated lived in new york city for a
couple years went upstate to law school
uh for a couple years but spent most of
my time in manhattan
getting into trouble and screwing up my
life moved to san francisco was a lawyer
there for a couple years moved here
in 96 was a lawyer
for a couple years bottomed out on drugs
and alcohol
went to treatment got sober sobriety was
my job
i still worked as a lawyer for many
years after that but sobriety was the
thing
you know and that was my introduction to
tools and new principles for how to
organize
my life and and live and and that's
still the lens through which i
you know process everything that i do
but
that was i mean i got sober in 98
and i feel like only now i'm starting to
really
feel like i'm expressing
the authentic version of who i am
[Music]
you